In Cuba, a tornado hit Havana, leaving at least three people dead and 172 injured.
The capital city was severely damaged by heavy winds and rain.
In Italy, Interior Minister Matteo Salvini is threatening to file charges...
...against the crew of a migrant rescue ship off the coast of Sicily.
The ship has been barred from docking in Italy,...
...stranding 47 migrants at sea.
In Russia, the Trump administration has lifted sanctions on Russian firms...
...with connections to oligarch Oleg Deripaska,...
...an ally of President Vladimir Putin...
...with ties to US President Trump's former campaign manager Paul Manafort.
The death toll continues to rise after a dam collapsed in southeastern Brazil.
At least 60 people are dead and 300 are still missing.
Finally from Venezuela,...
...opposition leader Juan Guaido has called for demonstrations this week...
...in his latest attempt to sway the Venezuelan military to his side...
...in a battle for the presidency against Nicolas Maduro.